you got an album coming out with with
joelle yes sir tomorrow night
uh
this is an album that has obviously
stirred up a lot of uh controversy it
stirred up a lot of opinions right uh
the records that you guys have put out
have been great so far for people who
are unaware this is the second time you
and joelle have put out a joint project
absolutely um
so let's get let's get first of all who
like like the initial idea
of
theming this album around the rise and
fall slaughterhouse right
where did the idea come from and
how long
have you guys been working on this body
of work um basically man
you know i had an opportunity for the
whole group
slaughterhouse
and um you know
let's give us the timeline how long ago
was that this was in august okay august
of 2021 august of 2021 i had opportunity
i felt it was a good opportunity for
where slaughterhouse is today you know i
mean um
we kind of dropped off the scene as the
streaming um era took off
you know what i mean our last album was
in 2012. this is that's 10 years ago
wow that's so great i'm [ __ ] old man
yeah dawg that's what i'm saying you
know what i'm saying like
so
our fans have been glass house
no
the glass house never came out no that's
right that was the that was the that was
the welcome to our house with the celo
single and all that yes sir so that was
10 years ago and our fans have been
waiting on music for 10 years you know
what i'm saying so
i had this opportunity i thought it was
a great opportunity um
uh i spoke to a couple other guys about
it
and
it was brought back to me that joe
didn't think that that was a good
opportunity you know i mean he didn't
want to do it so joe didn't want to do
it and roy said he didn't want to do it
if joe joe wasn't doing it now maybe
maybe royce felt like
it
it's not really slaughterhouse unless
it's all four
you know what i mean because and and so
it might not just be because of joe per
se it could have just been whatever but
i went back to the label and i was like
yo
what could you offer us for just us
three you know what i mean because joe
is retired and he's he doesn't seem
interested in this deal right here um
and they were like yo we rock and roll
with you let's do it you know and um
so when i brought that to royce he was
like nah
you know
slaughterhouse needs to be all four of
us so um
when we hung up the phone
me him and joelle me and joelle got back
on the phone the next day and was like
yo
i was like yo how'd you feel about that
conversation
and he said it felt like the group was
officially over and i said yeah it does
you know it's been 10 years
we bring the opportunity to the table
you know they don't want to do it you
know um for whatever reason you know
they're entitled of course to to to you
know want to do business or not
um i was like man
this [ __ ] is pretty pretty much over so
you know we sat on it for a minute
and then i called joelle back and i was
like yo man let's get back in there
he was like yeah man let's get back in
there and do something and it was just a
conversation what are we going to talk
about and i was like man let's talk
about
all the [ __ ] that happened
in slaughterhouse let's talk about the
good times the bad times let's just
let's give the fans some closure you
know what i'm saying and and let's give
ourselves some therapy
you know and uh that's how the whole
concept started rolling out and this was
in like
i would say
probably after september something like
that
october